you've just finished this huge tour of
arenas yes of Lee successful now you can
do a bit in the show about walks
different walks that you've observed in
life yeah do a whole thing about whoa
okay and I think the king of all walks
is when you walk purposefully in one
direction and set up shop you said walk
person one direction you immediately
realize you're being in the wrong
direction but you can't suddenly turn
around because that would look really
odd and so will turn into something like
do demonstrate yes we don't mean on feet
yeah well yeah along here here so you
would walk purposely like that realize
you're going the wrong direction and
then you have to look at your watch and
go ten past eleven that's interesting
okay well if it's ten past eleven
remember yeah if it's ten past eleven
I should probably I'll go in that
you have the best of the best of all but
you're the best walk of all in the show
you talk about the ultimate walk are the
ultimate walk is the pop star walk yeah
that Beyonce nails which I attempted to
do in my face please show so that's four
be very careful because it is a it's a
sort of one foot in front of the other
walk but it's sort of like this but you
have to be careful to it right because
if you do it wrong you might do it like
this and then you do what the looks like
you're scratching an awkward itch
properly do you want to go to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the attitude tank yeah that's good the
music going again
[Applause]
Timothy's watch the others thought about
it gone no it's a cross between
scratching an itch and John Cleese no
supermodel you know that kind of strange
[Music]
you